dort ist dein koffer nimm ihn daniel
dort ist dein koffer im in daniel
ach wo ist mein koffer
das dauert dabei
ne
ich habe mich schon zu früh gefreut
dollar
schnell daniel
dort schnell daniel
guten tag
ein taxi biete
wir brauchen ein taxi biete
guten tag
wohin wollen sie fahren
zu unser
teil bitte die adresse ist aber nie da
blau rosa 19 in palma
zu unserem hotel bitte die adresse ist
aber niederpleiser rosa 19 in palma
gerne das macht 32 euro sie können mit
karte oder euro bezahlen
gerne mit k
denn
gerne mit karte
hier bitte geben sie bitte ihren
zahlencode 1
sie können
der taxi wartete stelle ein taxi nehmen
und diese quittung vorweisen
sie können
der taxi wartete stelle ein taxi nehmen
und diese quittung vorweisen
wollen sie noch geld wechseln
ja
gehen sie geradeaus dann rechts um die
ecke
dort ist eine wechselstube gegenüber von
der apotheke
guten tag
der schweizer franken in euro wechseln
wie hoch ist der kurs guten tag ich
möchte schweizer franken in euro
wechseln
wie hoch ist der kurs
[Musik]
ein euro sind einen franken 12
wie viel geld möchten sie umtauschen
500 franken so dass gibt 446 euro
so dass gibt 446 euro
guten tag hier bitte wir haben schon
bezahlt guten tag hier bitte wir haben
schon bezahlt
wir wollen zu unserem hotel fahren bitte
moment lassen sie mich ihnen mit den
koffern helfen moment lassen sie mich
ihnen mit den koffern helfen
steigen sie bitte 1
steigen
bitte ein
woher kommen sie
[Musik]
ich komme ursprünglich aus den usa und
meine freundin aus polen
wir wohnen aber in der schweiz ich komme
ursprünglich aus den usa und meine
freundin aus polen
wir wohnen aber in der schweiz
interessant wie lange bleiben sie auf
mallorca interessant wie lange bleiben
sie auf mallorca eine woche ich habe
leider nicht länger ferien eine woche
ich habe leider nicht länger ferien es
gibt schöne strände im norden und osten
und westen der insel wenn sie wollen
kann ich sie dorthin fahren
es gibt schöne strände im norden und
osten und westen der insel wenn sie
wollen kann ich sie dorthin fahren
vielen dank für das angebot aber wir
werden einen mietwagen mieten und selber
die insel erkunden
vielen dank für
gebot aber wir werden einen mietwagen
mieten und selber die insel erkunden
haben sie einen tipp welchen strand wir
unbedingt sehen müssen
ja den strand cala torta im nordosten
der insel von palma sind es etwa eine
stunde fahrt aber es lohnt sich
ja den strand cala torta im nordosten
der insel von palma sind es etwa eine
stunde fahrt aber es lohnt sich
das meer ist dort glasklar
es gibt
für surfer es gibt quellen für surfer
die strände und hügel sind unbebaut
dort können sie gemütlich spazieren und
die ruhe genießen
entschuldigung fahren sie bitte
langsamer
natürlich entschuldigen sie ich habe
während des erzählens gar nicht auf den
tacho geschaut
natürlich entschuldigen sie ich habe
während des erzählens gar nicht auf den
tacho geschaut
so hier wären wir schon so
hier wären wir schon das macht noch 15
euro bitte
das macht noch 15 euro bitte
wir haben schon bezahlt wir haben ihnen
die quittung gegeben
das reicht aber nicht es ist teurer weil
wir so lange im stau gestanden sind
daniel ruft die polizei nein nein weil
sie es sind lassen wir es so daniel ruft
die polizei nein nein weil sie es sind
lassen wir es so
willkommen im hotel la playa guten tag
wir haben ein zimmer über die seite
ferienspaß punkt ch gebucht
guten tag wir haben ein zimmer über die
seite ferienspaß punkt ch gebucht
gerne kann ich ihren pass haben
hier bitte hier bitte frau nowak und
herr smith sie haben ein doppelzimmer
für eine woche mit frühstück gebucht
stimmt das
frau nowak und herr schmidt sie haben
ein doppelzimmer für eine woche mit
frühstück gebucht stimmt das
ja genau sie sind im zimmer 324 im
dritten stock
sie sind im zimmer 324 im dritten stock
dort ist er auf zu
dort ist er auf zu hier ist ihr
schlüssel
vielen dank hier ist ihr schlüssel
vielen dank
324 hier ist es
nein was ist das schau mal wir haben gar
keine aussicht aufs meer
[Musik]
ich habe aber ein zimmer mit blick aufs
meer reserviert
ich habe
ein zimmer mit blick aufs meer
reserviert
und schau mal hier und dem bett liegt
abfall
und schau mal hier unter dem bett liegt
und der fernseher funktioniert auch
nicht
das bett ist viel zu klein
das bad ist schmutzig ich rufe jetzt die
rezeption an und werde mich beschweren
das geht so nicht
das bad ist schmutzig ich rufe jetzt die
rezeption an und werde mich beschweren
das geht so nicht
[Musik]